you give the Democratic Party a lot of
wisdom you say look I try you try
there's anyone in the Democratic Party
whether a sitting congressman senator or
somebody who's involved in any kind of
thing take for Democrats do they ever
call you off the air and say bill what
are the three things I should just keep
hammering over and over and over again
it's so funny you asked me that because
the week before our editorial at the end
of the show was about me I'm the coach
of the Democrats and they put a case yep
okay gave them those tips that I thought
were apropos and Sheldon Whitehouse who
is a senator he did he called us the
next day and said I think you're right
I'd like to come on and talk about that
I just don't understand how people in
this country who considered themselves
so patriotic can see him side with other
countries to me that would be the whole
impeachment debate the whole campaign
against him running for president he
sides with countries that are not us
another word country's not named America
Putin at Helsinki he says yes I've
listened to my security people you know
the thank you for your service people
we're so big on that thank you for your
service but when Trump goes you too
tells you to go piss up a rope that's
okay so you see it seems to my side with
Kim jong-un when he says I'm not firing
missiles I believe him over really just
side with America I'm not I'm crazy that
way I want my president to side with my
country so your point of view is if you
were coaching someone if Jill Biden gets
the nomination satyam Joe here's the
three things right [ __ ] saying it
over and over again till people just
we'd exact like a mantra exactly like
you're teaching the alphabet to a
toddler and and make every Democrat this
is what the Republicans do they get
together in their evil lair and they get
a talking point and they all say it and
the Democrats never do that because
they're so diverse well you turn on the
news and MSNBC will show you a montage
of every site or saying the same exact
Republicans yeah yes why they're good
that's why they win because they do